bonjour alien assassy bonjour Qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé des propos de la
première année sur la Ligue des droits
de l'homme qui dit respecter l'histoire
de cette association et en même temps
s'interroger sur les prises de position
récente de la Ligue des droits de
l'homme qu'elle a qualifié d'ambigu
notamment vis-à-vis de l'islamisme
radical oui tout à fait j'ai trouvé très
choquante la réponse de madame la
ministre qui fait fier en fait de
l'histoire de la LDA chez des raisons
qui ont fait qu'elle a été créée en 1898
si je me souviens bien et tout ce qui
s'est passé ensuite dans notre pays et
la LDH a payé un lourd tribu comment
notamment pendant toute la période de
l'Occupation et donc renier toute cette
histoire je trouve ça éminemment grave
de la part de la première ministre et
puis cette volonté de trouver à chaque
fois des des des éléments pour
mettre à bas en quelque sorte cette
cette association en l'opposant avec la
avec la lycra sincèrement j'ai trouvé ça
mesquin de la part de la première
ministre je sais qu'elle ne veut pas des
avouer son ministère à l'intérieur qui a
quand même prononcé des propos assez
inquiétants vis-à-vis de la de la LDH on
en est là aujourd'hui et sincèrement je
suis très inquiète pour l'avenir malgré
cette histoire de la LDH quand même
est-ce qu'il ne faut pas s'interroger
par exemple autour de la manifestation
de Sainte-Souline quand la Ligue des
droits de l'Homme s'oppose à
l'interdiction de transport d'armes par
destination est-ce que ça pose pas
question il y a eu plusieurs versions
quand même sur le sujet la LDH était là
comme observatrice parce que vous le
savez elle est organisée de cette façon
ou sur le terrain il y a de nombreux
observateurs hommes et femmes au nom de
la LDH il y a plusieurs versions sur sur
ce qui s'est passé à sainte-solide moi
j'attends quand même de la première mise
qu'elle prête du recul sur sur tout le
cela donc elle elle rentre dans une
brèche pour mettre à bâche je le répète
et je j'assume mes propos une
association qui a une résonance quand
même assez particulière en France mais
au-delà aussi des frontières françaises
donc sincèrement je je trouve que ce
n'est pas à sa réponse n'était pas à la
hauteur de celle qu'on peut attendre
d'un Premier ministre d'une première
ministre en l'occurrence donc ces propos
vont mettre de nouveau de l'huile sur le
feu dans la crise sociale les tensions
qu'on connaît actuellement
je pense que effectivement je ne sais
pas quelle est la stratégie de fond du
gouvernement dans la période qui est que
nous traversons aujourd'hui dans le pays
avec la réforme de des retraites et
d'exigence de son retraites mais madame
la première mise mais de l'huile sur le
feu oui merci beaucoup merci pour votre
réaction au micro de public c'est non
[Musique]